Speaker 1: We are going to take a tour today
through three elements of the current American
right wing, and we're going to go through
them from the top down and it's going to be
about this movement called Trumpism.
It starts with Trump.
Then it goes to other elected officials who
are just as wacky or wackier.
And then it goes to the people that follow
them, and we're going to be able to see all
of this through a rally in Georgia that Donald
Trump held over the weekend.
We're going to look at what Trump said.
We're going to look at what other Republicans
said, and we'll look at what rally goers said.
So we are going to start here first with Donald
Trump.
I want to remind you, very small crowd.
This was the smallest Trump rally crowd in
Georgia in six years.
Barely 5000 people.
Trump always says there's 50000 people here.
He said at a recent rally, there were 87000
people there.
There weren't.
Those are just lies.
But it is true that Trump used to get 10 to
20000 people at these rallies, barely 5000
people, entire sections with very, very empty
seats.
So understand that context.
Let's jump right into the first clip where
Donald Trump seems to be very clearly saying,
I'm running, I'm running in 2024.
But he also says he's already won twice.
Speaker 4: I ran twice, I won twice, and I
did much better the second time.
And now we just may have to do it again.
Speaker 1: Imagine being this excited, this
excited that the guy who lost your party,
everything he lost the White House.
After one term, he oversaw Republicans losing
the Senate, he oversaw Republicans losing
the House.
They lost everything under Trump, and they
want more.
It's like a comedy show at this time, except
it's not.
Then this is a classic Trump unintelligible
rant.
It's something about gas prices.
But Trump is visibly confused.
He glitches.
I can't make heads or tails out of what he's
saying
Speaker 4: because energy is so expensive
today.
Gallons, you take a look at your.
Forget about it.
The pump, you take a look at a barrel.
Now it'll be two dollars.
It could be people saying it's going to go
up to if think of this.
People are saying.
Speaker 1: Oh, man.
A barrel might go all the way up to three
bucks that that would be the best deal on
a barrel, I could imagine per barrel.
Speaker 4: This is going over $100, it's going
over one hundred and fifty, it's going up
to two hundred and two hundred and fifty dollars.
So we're making these countries,
Speaker 1: by the way, they cut to a Vietnam
veteran who seems as confused as anybody in
the crowd.
Look at the look on this guy's face.
OK, so it does not appear that any of what
Trump is saying is is going to happen.
Oil went up, it got to about 125.
It came back down.
It may go up a little bit again, but what
Trump is saying is is just doesn't make any
sense whatsoever.
Trump also back to saying Putin is smart.
He's going, he's he's going back to Putin
is smart.
Speaker 4: But they me is Putin smart is Putin
was smart.
And I actually thought he was going to be
negotiating.
I said, that's a hell of a way to negotiate,
put 200000 soldiers on the border.
They should have never happened.
Certain things and that thing would have ended,
but they didn't have the common sense.
They want to know what to do.
We wouldn't have even had to give them.
I think he got he made a big mistake.
I think he made a big mistake.
All right.
Speaker 1: So it's completely unintelligible.
What sort of point Donald Trump is trying
to make there?
Then Trump told one of these sir stories where
he says they they said, Sir.
But this story is the opposite of relatable,
Trump says because of the supply chain issues,
Tiffany is out of rings, which the crowd really
can relate with.
Speaker 4: Who the hell ever heard of this
stuff?
You go to the stores, in the stores or the
companies are empty.
You're going to Tiffany.
Where is your ego surge?
We think we can have it in the next seven
to eight months.
Oh, that's wonderful.
The good news is you don't buy anything.
You save a lot of money.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: And of course, Trump's Trump's
crowd.
That's a common problem.
They're trying to buy rings at Tiffany and
they're on back order.
That's a really, really common problem.
Trump did address these confirmation hearings
of Judge Katon G. Brown Jackson.
And this is beyond parody.
Trump says that Jackson was disrespectful
to the Republican senators, if you can imagine
that.
Speaker 4: But Judge Jackson was unbelievably
disrespectful to Republican senators.
But that in many cases were really nicely
asking questions.
She had total disdain and even hatred for
them, and I understand that she's very proud
of the fact that she never once voted to support
President Trump on anything she owns.
Speaker 1: Yes, they were very nicely asking
questions like, Are babies racist?
Are you soft on people convicted for child
molestation or for explicit images of children?
Can you define a woman?
And other similarly respectful questions?
I mean, quite literally, you could just you
hear Trump and then you go, OK, the opposite
of that, that must be what is true.
Also, this is a clip that reminds us how desensitized
we are to the absurdity of what Trump now
says, where he can now essentially say other
governors haven't helped me with the coup.
And it doesn't even really make headlines
anymore.
Speaker 4: But he had no chance at the time,
in his opinion, against Stacey Abrams, who's
going to beat him.
And then he asked me to get involved, and
I had two rallies like this 52000 people at
each at the airport.
I said, Brian, you're going to win.
And he said, Alex, I'm sure as you could get
to win Brian.
I don't think so, sir.
I don't think I can beat her.
I said, Brian, look at this crowd, but they're
here for you.
And you know, what is do they worry if they
have their way for me?
And he ended up winning.
OK.
He ended up winning.
And then when we needed help, he wasn't there
for this country and it was to the country.
He wasn't there.
But the bad news is
Speaker 1: he wasn't there to help me with
the coup.
That's an insane thing for a former president
to say, and we are so desensitized to it that
that didn't even make headlines.
Two more quick clips here.
Of course, Trump is the perfect victim.
He is the one treated the most unfairly.
Everybody's so mean to Trump.
Speaker 4: Now, no president has ever suffered
like I've suffered at the hands of these animals.
People say to me, How the hell did you do
it?
And I can't even give him an answer.
I don't know.
I think I did it because I love you.
And because we have a job to do.
Speaker 1: Nobody has ever been treated this
unfairly.
And then last clip.
It is March, almost April of 2022.
Hillary Clinton has not been a candidate for
almost six years, and they're chanting, Lock
her up.
Speaker 4: I'm suing for millions of dollars
in damages against Crooked Hillary Clinton.
Unidentified: James Comey.
And John McCain.
Speaker 4: The two lovers who remember the
lovers, Peter Strzok and Lisa Page, and they're
going around suing everybody they use, the
FBI swept that was not a good idea.
They use the FBI servers.
Speaker 1: Therefore, law and order, therefore
due process, and yet they say lock someone
up who hasn't even been charged with a crime.
This is a very sick group of people.
But remember Trump's only part of it?
After the break, we'll look at his acolytes
who spoke at the rally and then we'll look
at the rally goers, which are, I would argue,
just as bad and potentially even more dangerous.
So we'll take a quick break.
We'll have all of these clips on our Instagram
at David Pakman show, and we'll be right back